In this portion of our course, we will go through a few simple use case scenarios using the DNA calibration library in Maya.
Using the scripts from the examples folder, we will use the DNA viewer runinMaya script to view metahumanDNA.
We will use the Propagate changes from Scene to DNA script to EditDNA files for exporting the head LODs as FBX.
So let's get started with DNA viewer.
The DNA viewer runinMaya script allows us to look at a DNA file and do things such as choose what LODs we want to assemble and what properties we want in them.
Now let's switch over to Maya and go through the steps for using this script to read a DNA file and assemble a functional rig.
Inside of a new Maya scene, I have opened up the script editor and docked it over here.
Over here, in File Explorer, I have the DNA calibration examples folder open.
I will select the DNA viewer runinMaya script and then right click on it and select Open with Notepad.
I will copy all of this and in the script editor, I will use the plus sign over here to add a new Python window.
Then I will paste the script here.
Next, I will select all of this, right click and select Execute.
The DNA viewer window will pop up.
Now the first thing we will do is go over here to assign the path of the DNA file we want to look at.
I will click here and search for the file.
The DNA files will be located in the DNA calibration data folder in the folder named DNA files.
I am going to select the DNA file named Lena that I have added from the Unreal Fest Zip and now I can select Load DNA.
Next, we can select what LODs we want to assemble and what properties we want in them.
For example, if we only want to assemble LOD 0 and the head mesh only, we can select only those two things.
To assemble a fully functional rig, we will want to select all of the LODs and all of their contents.
We can do this by choosing Select All Meshes.
Now for the build options, I will check on Joints, Blend Shapes and Skin Clusters.
Notice that the rig logic will be grayed out.
Let's go here and assign the GUI path.
This is located in the data folder and since we are using the latest version of MetaHuman,
I will open up the MH4 folder and select the GUI that's in here.
This will load the faceboard and selectable controls.
Next, we will assign the Analog GUI path.
This is located in the data folder right here.
This loads the GUI for the controls affecting the I direction.
Next, we will assign the Additional Assembly Script.
This is located in the data folder and again since we want to use the latest version of MetaHuman,
I will open up the MH4 folder and select this one.
Now that we have assigned these, the RigLogic option can now be checked on
and this will connect all of the functions of the rig giving it behavior.
We can now select Process.
We will get a warning from Maya asking us if we want to save the existing scene.
I will select Discard.
This will begin to assemble the full rig and everything in the DNA file
and this may take a moment.
Now that it is loaded, I can minimize this
and over here we can see the Lena DNA file.
Since we enabled RigLogic,
we can select a control
and we'll see that when we move it, the face is fully functional.
And this is how you can use the DNA viewer run in Maya script.
Now let's do a quick review before we move on.
We just went through the steps of using the DNA viewer run in Maya script.
This script allows us to visualize a DNA file,
choose what LODs we want to assemble and what properties we want in them.
To read and create a functional rig in Maya,
start by pasting the entire script in the script editor
and then run the entire command.
Once DNA viewer pops up, assign the path of the DNA file you wish to view.
This will commonly be located in the data DNA files folder.
Then select low DNA.
Next, select the LODs and the contents you want to assemble.
If you want all the LODs, then select all meshes.
Next, choose the build options.
To assemble a fully functioning rig,
check on joints, blend shapes and skin clusters.
To enable rig logic, you will need to assign the GUI path,
which is located in the data folder.
This will load the faceboard GUI and as mentioned,
you will want to use the updated rig,
so select the GUI file located in the data MH4 folder.
Assign the analog GUI path,
which is the GUI for the controls affecting the eye direction.
And then assign the additional assembly script path,
which is used for final tweaks or metadata.
And this is located in the data MH4 folder for the updated rigs.
Once all of these paths have been assigned,
rig logic and the build options can be enabled.
This will connect all of the functions of the rig.
Finally, you can select process,
and this will assemble the full rig and everything in it.
Now, let's move on to the next section,
where we will use the propagate changes to DNA script,
and make some minor modeling changes to the rig,
and edit the DNA file.